on se parle aujourd'hui du chiot midouze
alors je vous ai présenté il ya quelques
jours les chinois mais 12e sommet de ce
projet fait une vidéo je vous ai fait
j'ai fait une vidéo d'ailleurs je n'en
ai même parlé dans le podcast vous
invite à venir vous abonner à ma chaîne
de podcasts une chaîne à paris j'ai
vraiment voulu les séparer parce que les
contenus sont pas les mêmes donc je vous
mets le lien dans la description d'une
échelle du podcast à les découvrir il ya
une interview qui est super intéressante
de pierre allons voir quel directeur
marketing de shinobi france et qui nous
parle des chiots mais 12 de la série
chuck b12 et qui nous parle également de
la stratégie de la marque vous allez
voir on apprend plein de choses vraiment
intéressantes sont chez un ami une fois
de plus le lien est en mal d'un
description podcast vidéo il ya des
vieux podcast audio mais maintenant tout
cela en vidéo donc ça c'est vachement
bien allez-y à lester à un dock de
qu'aujourd'hui on disparaît de celui là
le chien mais de nous alors pas du chien
mais 12 procès dans quelques jours pour
l'instant c'est vraiment le ciom et 12
passes que ce chiot médouze il est quand
même un peu différent du sien au 1012
pros et on fera un peu moins néanmoins
je garde quand même les grandes lignes
et ben oui c'est la même série il fut
très jolies promesses et moi je trouve
pas mal mais je trouve trop cher et peut
tout vous écoute
[Musique]
achiou michel michaut michao michao me
tue nous régale si jamais tu nous fait
rêver les prix un petit peu moins on est
quasiment à 900 euros n'est gelé l'hôtel
à
899 euros 90 sur une version 8 gigas de
ram 256 go de stockage donc bon pourquoi
pas on ne dira un prix comme ça ça me
convient c'est intéressant c'est du haut
de gamme chez omis augmente sa gamme
même si très évident que ce ne sera pas
le smartphone celui là où même le disco
qui se vendra le plus les smartphones
qui sont vendues plus son esprit la
gamme renmin hot on va se parler des
rémy plus dur et demi note je pense rémi
notre onze d'ailleurs déjà parlé de ses
smartphones là les smartphones qu'on va
retrouver aujourd'hui les chiots midouze
déchirure de ce procès où je mets deux
aujourd'hui c'est plus des smartphones
d'image pour montrer que la marque
innove que la marque c'est faire du très
haut de gamme et sait se mettre à la
hauteur de tous les autres clairement au
niveau du tarif aussi alors à 900 euros
je vous explique moi ce qui se passe je
trouve qu'on a un très bel écran ça il
n'y a aucun souci là-dessus j'adore
l'écran je trouve bien maîtrisée
légèrement incurvé sur le côté et a un
côté très immersif il ya un très beau
boulot qui ne fuit pas la marque là
dessus ça me va bien pour venir scrollé
pour venir naviguer pour bien faire tout
ce que vous voulez on a un truc qui
réactif qui est beau qui marche bien on
est sur du 120 hertz adaptatif ça aussi
ça me convient plutôt bien et je me
retrouve bien l'expérience logiciel elle
me convient bien c'est du mirail 13 basé
sur android 12 ok j'ai du thème son
budget du thème clair comme on est sur
dieu l'amoled ici quand ce sont les
thèmes sombres et tout ce qui est noir
mince et des pixels qui sont éteints
donc ça veut dire ça ne consomme pas au
niveau de ma batterie donc ça ça me
plaît bien également qu'est ce que je
vais trouver intéressant je vais trouver
intéressant la calibration le taux
d'actualisation aussi d'avoir un taux
d'actualisation dynamique là je suis sur
1 120 hertz si je souhaite je peux
rester sur soi du 120 hertz tout le
temps soit du 60 hertz ou le temps je le
mets en dynamique comme ça il va changer
automatiquement en fonction des
applications que j'utilise aînés ça
c'est pas un truc tout nouveau qu'on
retrouve ici dans le haut de gamme ce
soit ici ou ailleurs haut de gamme et
très haut de gamme donc sa samba bon pas
là ça me va bien les schémas de couleur
aussi je peux changer plus saturés moins
saturé j'ai des paramètres avancés bref
ça me convient comme il ya pas de souci
donc côté expérience au niveau de la
dalle tout va bien l'expérience audio
elle est un petit peu un petit peu en
dessous alors oui en tout cas ça très
intéressant au niveau du positionnement
des haut parleurs sur ce modèle là vous
avez des hauts parleurs stéréo un de
chaque côté sur l'autre à 4 haut
parleurs en or par adam le test du
xiaomi 12 pro d'ici quelques jours donc
je vous invite à bien vous abonner
cliquez sur le petit bouton rouge si les
rouches et vous n'êtes pas abonné erik
todts vous êtes abonné je les actionner
la cloche comme ça vous serez vous avec
une prochaine vidéo rivera alors
regardez nous on fait un truc marrant le
vomi les haut parleurs juste là alors
haut parleurs avec harman kardon est bon
c'est une signature c'est du marketing
un là et l'autre qui est juste là à sa
place et c'est vrai qu'habituellement on
tient plutôt son smartphone comme ça et
si vous le tenez comme ça vous bloquez
les haut parleurs et là on a les boutons
de volume tout ce qu'il faut faire il
faut le tournez vous le mettez comme ça
et là vous pouvez poser vos doigts sans
venir obstruée et ça pose pas de
problème est là pour venir regarder
alors tout qui moi me gêne un peu c'est
que mes boutons de volume ils sont bas
du coup ça moins pratique à voir mais
bouton l'a donc j'aurais préféré que je
suis au milieu de nous mettre ses petits
haut parleurs sur le aux combles inverse
par rapport à l'infrarouge voiliers de
ce côté là et comble inverse par rapport
aux tiroirs de cartes sim ici je trouve
ça beaucoup plus malins dont je trouve
que l'emplacement est pas dingue déjà il
ya un petit truc et en plus de ça c'est
juste une habitude moi je suis habitué
lorsque j'ai un smartphone comme ça il
ya un petit déséquilibre c'est normal
d'avoir un haut-parleur principal qui
situe là avec le meilleur spectre avec
un son un peu plus grave est ici ça peut
plus médium là c'est un peu inversés
j'aime dans l'autre sens bon c'est du
point de détail vous me direz il ya
notre que j'aime pas trop de ce côté là
c'est comme j'ai inversé eh ben je sens
mon blog photo et celui là dans ma main
à l'intérieur de la paume de ma main et
je tiens un peu moins bien et simplement
pour ça c'est pour la l'idée de
raccrocher le vélo parleurs comme ça
c'est pas dingue et puis il ya nos
troupes se trouve que le son est quand
même assez médiocre alors l'âge de foot
a beau regarder je trouve vraiment
vraiment médium alors on se dit je vais
le bc j'aurais mode médium ouais un peu
mais pas trop quand même c'est un peu
qui a envoyé surtout celui là là ça
pique un peu les oreilles celui là un
peu moins mais ça reste quand même
extrêmement médiocre donc l'expérience
audio là dessus tel que vous l'avez au
travers des haut-parleurs n est pas
parfaite le mieux c'est de dire brancher
des écouteurs externe en bluetooth comme
ça vous serez tranquille vous profiterez
de la meilleure expérience passée le
premier petit bémol que je vais venir
apporter ici à côté de ça l expérience
pure et simple au niveau de l'affichage
massa marche vachement bien les crocs et
hop on a su aucun problème maintenant il
ya un autre truc à voir c'est le format
parce que ce format il est plutôt
intéressant comme on a un écran qui
paraît être un peu long comme ça ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire qu'en fait si on
réduit légèrement la largeur donc on a
une très bonne prise en main et ça sur
un smartphone pour moi c'est vachement
important parce que votre smartphone
vous le prenez vous allez le bouger
naviguer comme ça voilà bref si on n'a
pas une bonne prise en main on peut se
dire je peux le faire tomber je peux le
cas c'est ici vous êtes peinard ya aucun
problème donc la prise en main je la
trouve vraiment très très bonne et je
trouve que je suis au mit a bien bossé
là-dessus autre point petit retour que
je vous fais c'est que j'aime bien
l'esthétique se voit du photo comme ça
je trouve super beau alors bon c'est pas
ça que l'ami a changé l'histoire mais je
trouve que c'est aussi une fois de plus
très sympa et très très belle finition
ici de la part de la marque donc ça ça
me va aussi entre éléments qui est
extrêmement important ici ben qu'est ce
qu'on veut on veut effectivement de la
performance alors je vous le montre je
vous ai fait un petit test avec en tout
26 marques j'arrive à 945 1099 qui me le
positionne quand même vachement bien
alors ici il faut savoir qu'on est sur
un stade ragots djen djen one comme on
veut et qui lui confère beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de puissance
donc vous aurez tout ce qui convient ici
pour venir jouer à des jeux n'importe
quel jeu sur android ça ira aucun
problème donc si vous êtes gamer si vous
êtes dit mme si vous voulez un
smartphone qui tartinent et qui avance
du feu de dieu que vous pouvez y aller
là dessus est absolument aucun souci ils
ont vraiment prévu le truc qui marche et
qui va très très bien donc ça c'est très
très cool alors vous savez il ya un truc
qui est intéressant au niveau des
smartphones c'est comme il les aime bien
faire des gammes il faut des différences
entre les produits il faut forcément
différentiel est chaud et doux du show
me disent pro même si dans l'ensemble
ils se ressemble quand même beaucoup
mais il faut des différences différence
au niveau de la taille de l'écran
différence au niveau de la batterie au
niveau du bloc de charges au niveau de
la photo alors la différence au niveau
de l'écran cdu combien cdu 6,73 sur le
pro contre du 6,28 ici il ya une
différence entre sûr qu'il ya une
différence la batterie c'est minime on
se parle de 4600 millan paire eur /
modèles professionnels versus 4500
millan paire eur autant vous dire que il
n'ya quasiment pas de différences sont
quasiment les mêmes pack de batteries
donc ça va pas changer grand chose par
contre il ya une différence qui sont
venus au pairay qui moi me fait râler r
je vous le dis très clairement je suis
hyper hyper hyper transporte chela pour
l'atripla transpromo c'est qu'en fait
dans la boîte du chiot mais nous ils
nous ont mis ce blog de charge 60 7
watts alors bon hockey comme dire à 60 7
watts et rapide c'est bien mais ouais
mais laurent pourquoi parce que dans le
modèle professionnel on a un bloc de
charge de 120 watts pourquoi est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui sur un smartphone que je
vais payer quasiment neuf cents euros je
vais avoir un bloc de charges on va
m'emmener à l'économie parce que c'est
là c'est vraiment aller à l'économie il
faut ces différences dans la gamme ça ça
me fait râler non je vous explique
pourquoi parce qu'en fait l'année
dernière souvenez vous avec le chiot me
on se tait proche il ya au minou avait
sorti un smartphone haut de gamme c'est
pas du milieu de gamme c'est plutôt du
haut de gamme avec un bloc de charge 120
watts mais qui était quand même beaucoup
moins cher que le chiot 2012 aujourd'hui
sauf que pour allégeance sérieuses
passes 650 euros je vous dirais une
bêtise on est à 20 blocs de charge 120
aujourd'hui j'ai un smartphone 1 900
euros et je n'ai pas de bloc de charge
120 watts alors je sais pourquoi ils
font ça parce qu'il faut bien en mettre
un peu plus dans le modèle pro si vous
avez le même bloc de charges dont je
suis homme est douce que dois je suis
ami 12 pro ça marche plus enfin j'en
sais rien alors je suis d'accord 67
watts et quand même rapide ça va bien
mais on track presque du simple au
double quoi enfin il ya un moment ça ne
va pas je comprends différence de
batterie je comprend une différence de
taille d'écran je comprends différence
au niveau de la photo mais un bloc de
charge sérieusement donc ça ça m'embête
un petit peu après et franchement si
vous voulez l'acheter à 900 euros soyez
tranquilles la recharge 67 voix de saint
avit après il faut savoir que vous avez
exactement la même recharge sans fil 50
watts d'un côté de l'autre et la même
charge inversée donc ça ça ira très bien
y aura pas de souci non plus après il ya
un autre truc qui me fait râler alors je
vous explique pourquoi c'est au niveau
de la config photo alors on a un
triptyque c'est à dire on a trois grand
angle ultra grand-angle télé macro ont
été les maquereaux alors j'en prends un
conflit comme ce que je fais a apprise
par coeur ici j'ai un capteur principal
de 50 méga pixels je me dis ok ça fait
mégapixels je voudrais faire un point
que 88 bon ok très beau capteurs ça me
va ensuite je vais avoir un ultra
grand-angle c'est du kwassa c1 13
mégapixels ici vers 6h50 mégapixels sur
le pro aucun qui ait pas de problème on
espère le modèle standard on n'est pas
serein monnaie professionnels sympa bien
mettez les bacs rocky les maquereaux de
5 mégapixels voilà c'est à dire que en
fait là à ce prix ce triptyque là il est
bien et vous allez voir les photos un
grand pan nous travaillons temps et ça
marche vachement bien la macro c'est un
peu moi ça mais de toute façon dont la
macro sur les capteurs de 5 mégapixels
ou 2 mégapixels j'y crois pas ça c'est
mon truc je me dis juste que quitte à
payer un smartphone 900 euros j'aimerais
bien ne pas me retrouver avec la même
configuration qu'à smartphone milieu de
gamme que je vais payer 400 500 euros
voire des x 300 euros alors attention ce
ne sont pas les mêmes capteurs dans un
smartphone à 300 euros par tonne à 500
euros que je retrouverais ici sur mon
grand angle et monde ultra grand-angle
mais l'idée de se dire sur un smartphone
à 900 euros on se rapproche des 1000
euros quand même je n'ai pas de télé
objectifs c'est à dire que en réalité je
vais avoir deux capteurs principaux qui
vont intéresser deux éléments de
photographies qui vont intéresser mon
grand angle et monde ultra grand-angle
le thé les maquereaux et m'en fous j'ai
pas faire des photos de maquereaux tous
les jours ça n'apporte rien donc
j'aurais trouvé ça intéressant que xiaot
me viennent de mettre ici un
téléobjectif avec une différence il
aurait fallu mettre une différence toute
façon entre le modèle pro et ce modèle
là lessard était normal et le ic parce
que en fait en terme d' usage sur un
smartphone il serait de plus à 900 euros
et ça il faut le garder eh bien je suis
limité et ça ça ne paraît pas normal et
ça me parait embêtant noria de plus en
plus de constructeurs qui font ça ils
ont voulu vraiment mettre un fossé entre
d'un côté la modèle professionnel et le
xiaomi 12 parce qu'on va le vendre plus
cher et parce qu'il faut différencier
les gammes mais non enfin jeunes ont
enfin je sais pas qu'on aime moins loin
qu'on dise ok je vais jusqu'à un zoom
numérique x 10 et de l'autre côté
jusqu'à 1 x 30 x 50 x sont ok ça a un
sens mais pourquoi vous ne mettez pas
que tu aies l'objectif you mais enfin ça
c'est vraiment dommage ça me fait râler
parce que une fois de plus 900 euros ou
un smartphone c'est beaucoup d'argent et
ne pas avoir un 900 euros un tel
objectif j'ai l'impression qu'on a un
rétropédalage en arrière passe à
quelques temps vous la vie en temps des
modèles où on peut le trouver mais là a
quasiment 900 euros sur un smartphone
très haut de gamme non enfin ça voilà
moi ça me fait râler quand ça n'enlève
rien aux qualités photos des deux autres
capteurs et je vous montre le résultat
dans quelques instants mais voilà quoi
enfin je sais pas vous êtes d'accord
avec moi ou pas de redites le mans bat
en commentaire souvenez-vous il ya
quelques jours je vous montrais lors de
ma première prise en main des photos que
je trouve un petit peu jaune pourquoi
parce qu'on avait le ciel du sahara du
sable du sahara on avait une ambiance
très jeune dans paris d'ailleurs après
partout en france a donné des résultats
comme ça alors le temps est passé
le sahara est parti de chez nous il est
retourné je ne sais où peut-être ça et
on a tout autre chose à regarder voilà
on arrive là dessus alors déjà voyez on
n'a plus le jeune du sahara on regarde
les photos qui sont très bonnes et ce
chien ont mis 12 mars vachement bien ici
c'est le capteur principal regarder on a
le soleil là on voit bien toute la
limite de la façade rien et cramer on a
bien le toit ici on voit bien les
façades ya un très beau travail
logiciels qui est fait ici la partie
éclairée on la voit drôlement bien on la
voit de la même manière que la partie
qui n'est pas éclairée de l'autre côté
donc il ya super boulot logiciel qui a
été fait ici au niveau du traitement de
la photo sur l'ultra grand temps que
c'est pareil ça marche bien vous n'avez
pas d'image déformés vous avez bien
votre soleil zae bien le détourage ici
vous voyez bien qu'autour de votre
bâtiment voyez bien le toit fin bref il
ya très très très très beau boulot qui
est fait ici on peut venir nous mais on
se rapproche alors là on est sur un zoom
x 2 ça c'est le foie de également par le
haut alors attention celle-ci du zoom
numérique en à 14,50 mégapixels un
diacre op dans l'image parce qu'on n'a
pas de tels objectifs une fois de plus
donc c'est tout dit numérique en x 2 ça
va il faut à 5 on sait déjà perdu c'est
là où il faudrait un téléobjectif parce
que on perd vraiment précision et c'est
pas beau garder foi 5 sur le haut bas on
y voit plus rien là regardez c'est pas
terrible et ça marche plus qu'on va
jusqu'au x 10 numérique et c'est pas
beau du tout là où d'autres smartphones
dans cette gamme de prix là aller à
quelque chose près peuvent faire des
choses beaucoup mieux on sera au 10 mai
100 numérique voilà une fois de plus
sauf odyssée 6 alors je vous montre un
quotidien quelques petites photos
regarder je trouve qu'ils ont fait un
super boulot d'un point de vue logiciel
il y a un côté où je sais pas on a
l'impression de prendre l'arbre en
pleine gueule là je sais pas si vous
allez vous en rencontrant travers
l'écran de votre ordinateur mais on les
feuilles il ya une netteté dans les
feuilles qui est vraiment super rebelle
un beau traitement au niveau du ciel
bleu derrière je trouve ça vraiment beau
assez bluffant lors on voit qu'il ya un
travail logiciels derrière là on le voit
ici au niveau des petites de petit con
tour qu'on va retrouver un homme bien
sous un petit peu là voyez ici là tout
ce travail là pour venir nous faire
ressortir les feuilles et une vraie
analyse regardez là ça nous fait un tout
petit contours blanc pour nous faire
ressortir les feuilles ailes détachées
du ciel bleu là et alors on voit ce qui
est un côté effectivement très net c'est
parce que l'algorithme il vient vous
poussez un peu la matière pour vous la
prenez en pleine tête et je trouve ça
vraiment vraiment vraiment vraiment très
très très efficace avec l'ultra grand
angle on aura un peu moins ce côté hyper
dead tv pour autant ça marchera bien et
on voit que les algorithmes aussi à
bosse très très bien derrière alors une
fois de plus on peut venir ce zoom et je
vous ai fait quelques effets en immense
histoire de vous montrer mais bon on va
pas le faire alors quelques petit test
au niveau de la macro une fois de plus
je ne suis pas convaincu et je n'aime
pas ça alors j'ai essayé deux trois
trucs un peu plus loin vous allez voir
seront un peu moins pire déjà il faut
trouver la bonne distance et c'est pas
extrêmement évident alors là également
une photo dans des conditions un peu
plus sombre et qui se dit très éclairé
au fond et va s'asseoir et s'en sort pas
trop mal regarder au fond c'est pas
cramé ça marche bien je vous ai passé
sur l' ultra grand-angle a envoyé un peu
le festival des poubelles ici j'aurais
dû m'avance un peu plus dans la rue mais
c'est pas grave ça marche bien et je
peux le dire ensuite vous mais très
légèrement bon c'est toujours un peu un
peu la même histoire petites photos que
je trouvais aussi intéressante comme ça
ça vous montre ce côté là avec le petit
quota peu floutée sur la place des
vosges derrière et puis ce mur en fait
c'est de cette colonne qui est super
rebelle elle message qui a été sympa fut
rendu ultra grand angle on s'en sort
également peut venir nous met un peu
mais pas plus ce côté là est aussi
intéressant parce que là je suis
sous des arcades de la place des vosges
je suis dans un côté un peu plus à
l'ombre et vous avez quelque chose de
très lumineux de l'autre côté pour
autant on a bien tous les détails sur la
roche à l'intérieur on le voit bien on
voit bien le toit également ici enfin la
voûte intérieure et on voit bien et
c'est partie ensoleillé qui ressort bien
on voit bien le 6 à l'extérieur s'est
pas particulièrement cramer et je trouve
que ça fonctionne bien il ya un beau
travail qui est fait une fois de plus là
dessus on peut faire la même chose sur
l'autre à grand temps les résultats sera
très très homogène très très similaire
et ça marche bien pour voir qu'on n'est
pas sur le modèle pro parce que ce
modèle pro vous avez un grand-angle un
ultra grand-angle un tel objectif c'est
tout du 50 méga pixels mais sans
dentelles en quelques jours et malhache
faut que ça marche quand même bien alors
on peut venir zoom et un peu ça
fonctionne mais au-delà de ça on va pas
trop loin fois deux pas plus également
la place des vosges ici regardez ça
marche vachement bien c'est super joli
on peut venir à 600 l'ultra grand temps
chaud qui est un taux qui est vraiment
raccord au niveau des couleurs garder le
traitement la voyait d'ici là entre le
grand temps les ultra grand-angle ça
fonctionne ça fonctionne vraiment je
suis remis à très très très très bien
bossé pareil ici en continu superbe
gestion de la lumière et même sur des
choses un petit peu plus sombre ça
marche moins on voit foyer il ya une
très très très belle cohérence toujours
un peu la même chose alors montre peu
sont bien pas trop zoomer parce qu'on
perd un peu en qualité bon peut pas ici
à bastille hop là on évite trop il ya
des choses qui sont très sympa et je
trouve que ce smartphone il fonctionne
bien en photo sur le grand-angle et l'
ultra grand-angle alors je vous ai fait
quelques photos un peu après à garder
sur la macro j'ai tenté des choses en
plus d'essayer de chercher des choisi
d'envoyer ce temps aux essais sur sa pas
évident de trouver en fait la bonne
distance pour venir soutenir la macro et
pour des résultats qui sont un peu à
certains pour ça c'est un peu rigolo
parce que voyez on a bien ces espèces de
petites pilosité au niveau de la plante
mais on reste derrière et pas beau donc
j'ai un truc à un endroit mais le reste
est flou autour pas là j'ai du mal à
content de cette maquereau a trouvé ça
bien j'ai du mal c'est pas mon truc on
rappelle que ça sert à rien n'y a pas
réellement d'usagé voilà je vous ai pris
la plus petite photo en plus pour vous
montrer cancer des photos nues alors les
photos nues son intéressante aussi parce
que sookie marche pas mal dans
l'ensemble il est quand même plutôt bien
il ya un bon traitement logiciel
derrière on a un bon capteur ça marche
bien sûr le grand angle sur l'ultra
grand temps que c'est pas ouf ça devient
un prêt si ce n'est pas parfait mais ça
c'est normal un petit peu on peut venir
nous mais légèrement mais pas trop
regarder je me remets ici sur mon
capteur principal sur mon grand-oncle
aux conditions nuit ça va plutôt pas mal
ultra grand-angle ans d'oubli et là
c'est pareil tous que mon grand angle il
est pas mal regardez là mais lumière la
gestion elle est plutôt bonne et si au
niveau de mes belvédère au niveau des
fenêtres au niveau du ciel en est sûr
une nuit qu'ils couchent attention il
doit 20 heures tout comme ça mais ça
marche bien ultra grand-angle c'est un
parfait il ne trouve ça quand même pas
mal regardé dans l'ensemble ils meurent
sans même un petit peu de détails au
niveau des arbres que vous avez le
niveau des branchages donc non il ya un
boulot qui est intéressant et qui est
bien maîtrisé une fois de plus de la
part monsieur ici on a un truc
intéressant deux jours grand angle ultra
grand-angle la nuit grand temps toute la
partie photo vidéo jeu-là consacrerait
davantage aux tests de lui là le xiaomi
12 pro donc on en reparlera dans
quelques jours je vous invite une fois
plus à venir vous abonner parce que on a
à peu près la même idée d'un point de
vue logiciel de ce qu'on peut venir
faire on aura une petite différence au
niveau du capteur mais en terme de vidéo
vous regardez sur tout ce qu'on peut
faire avec le choc de ce procès là ça
sera le plus intéressant si vous avez en
usage de la vidéo concerne la création
essayer ça brille déjà comme ce qu'on a
ici au niveau de la photo est quand même
plutôt pas mal même si ce côté tel
objectif manquant me fait extrêmement
râler après vous avez un smartphone qui
est extrêmement complet on a du wifi 6
me fit 6e du nfc on a une double carte
sim 5 g ici donc moi je trouve pas mal
qu'est ce qu'ils racontent et à qui il
est destiné ce smartphone et c'est ça
qui est intéressant c'est vraiment
l'idée de se dire ok en termes de tarifs
j'ai 200 euros d'écart contre le chiot
midouze et shlomi 12 pro alors 200 euros
c'est beaucoup d'argent c'est une
certitude mais quand je suis ici à
899 euros 90 c'est que ici je suis à
combien très précis 1099 euros 90
montrouge soit 900 et je suis à 1100
euros j'ai 200 euros d'écart entre ces
deux smartphones et je me dis que ça
représente beaucoup d'argent il ya deux
choses est ce que ça vaut le coup de
maître 200 euros tout de suite plus ici
une horaire altesse d'ici quelques jours
et le deuxième point c'est est ce que ça
vaut le coup d'attendre un peu que les
prix baissent un petit peu pour venir se
positionner sur ces smartphones un peu
moins cher ça peut aussi valoir que oui
c'est ça dépend si vous devez changer
tout de suite à l'instant t où si vous
avez encore un petit peu de temps si
vous voulez changer tout de suite à un
instant t je vous mets liens dans la
description à l'isie et faites vous
plaisir donc non ce smartphone diva est
destiné à tous ceux qui veulent un bel
écran pour le multimédia c'est pas à
l'écran le plus grand le plus grand s'il
prolongera comprimé qui veulent un bel
écran bien calibré pour le multimédia
attention pour profiter de la meilleure
expérience pensé à mettre des écouteurs
sans fil ça marchera bien à tous ceux
qui veulent un très joli smartphones
avec beaucoup de performances pour venir
jouer à tous les jeux vous voulez vous
avez beaucoup de parfums il n'y a pas de
problème vous avez une autonomie aussi
qui est bonne a qu'une recharge qui est
rapide même si c'est pas la plus rapide
vous l'aurez compris ça me fait un peu
mais bon ça marche bien donc on a un
truc qui est vachement bien pour venir
se connecter à 12 filles à l'année on
est extrêmement rapidement et de la 5g
dans la rue extrêmement rapidement pour
regarder des films des séries pour du
multimédia pour du gaming pour tout ce
que vous voulez vous avez un très joli
smartphone à 900 euros même si vous
l'avez compris il meurt en voir un petit
truc mais je trouve bien et puis
n'oubliez pas il ya les pré commandes
jusqu'au 29 mars ils vous offrent leurs
nouvelles monde connecté la plus haut de
gamme elle s'appelle comment elle
s'appelle la watch s ans et elle coûte
je connais pas les prix par coeur un vol
un début écoute 269 euros 99 et elle
vous est offert jusqu'au 29 mars les
précommandes sont disponibles je vous
met une fois de plus le lien en bas par
la description si ce chiot midouze vous
fait de l'oeil et que la config que vous
avez là au niveau de la photo vous
suffit et qu'un bloc de chats 67 watsa
vous suffit pas vous pouvez y aller les
yeux fermés c'est un très beau
smartphone maintenant si vous vous posez
la question du mettre un peu plus
d'argent de mettre 200 euros de plus est
de regarder ce qui se passe du côté du
chiot médus pro et bien je vous donne
rendez-vous d'ici quelques jours parce
que d'ici quelques jours et audrey mon
retour définitif sur ce smartphone photo
vidéo écran performance charge et là ça
va être cool on dessine nous embrasse
prenez soin de vous et à très bientôt
bisous ciao
[Musique]